[Musique]
quand j'étais petit j'étais prêt tin un
jour avant la rentrée des classes
ma mère comme toute mère inquiète m'a
fait lire recommandations et la lune qui
m'a particulièrement et de line ne dit
jamais que ta maman et j'y vais on
parlait jamais religion la maison et je
comprenais pas pourquoi je pouvais être
en paix coupe danger pour quelque chose
qui m'échappe et complètement sa
renforcer ma timidité et je me suis
plongé dans une stratégie de repli on
recrée des jeux en retrait des groupes
en retrait des activités collectives
mater souffrir bien sûr parce que je
voyais bien je passe à côté de choses à
14 ans crise d'adolescence le monde me
sens des menaces ans j'ai décidé de
rentrer dans la menace j'ai annoncé à
mes parents j'ai arrêté le piano j'ai
arrêté la danse classique et que j'ai
démarré là ils se sont dit c'est une vie
d'ado ça va lui passer
bah ça a duré 18 ans 18 ans au rythme
des compétitions 18 ans de combat 18 ans
sur les rings
alors on dit souvent c'est bien parce
que t'as pas justice de l'emploi
en fait je pense surtout que je
corresponds pas l'image qu'on se fait
tabasser
j'ai envie de faire un petit sondage
parmi vous combien pense que la boxe
c'est un sport et l'a26 tape dessus
celui qui t'a pas le plus fort le plus
longtemps on aura gagné ce qu'on est ce
que vous pouvez lever la main dans le
public ceux qui ont plus ou moins cette
conception les yeux parfait on va avoir
plein de choses à se dire
j'ai pour partager avec vous ma
conception de la boxe et plus peut-être
faire évoluer un peu la vôtre
la boxe est un sport particulier parce
que ce qui est en jeu c'est mon
intégrité physique ce qui est en jeu
c'est même mon identité parce que
prendre des coups au visage c'est
toucher à un symbole de l'identité
parce que ce qui est en jeu et précieux
les stratégies vont se déployer ou est
puissante
c'est de ça dont je vais vous parler
pour cela je vais vous emmener au coeur
d'un combat qui a été très important
pour moi un championnat du monde contre
la tenante du titre
on parlait que d'elle une russe et en
plus c'était sur mes terres en alsace
je vais vous emmener vivre ce combat de
l'intérieur des vestiaires jusqu'au rire
pourquoi des vestiaires parce que dans
les desserts 10 passe beaucoup de choses
imaginez le vestiaire de c'est
l'antichambre du combat sûr que je vais
y rester jusqu'à ce qu'on m'appelle pour
monter sur le ring
on rentre c'est pas très joyeux un
vestiaire ces petites salles au
carrelage verdâtre lumière blafarde
je rentre je partage le vestiaire avec
deux autres coureurs
ordre de passage de passe en avant
dernière position ça veut dire que je
vais attendre trois heures le combat est
loin et en même temps une proche je
m'installe dans un petit espace devant
les petits soigneusement des affaires on
savait toutes trois minutes on encore
pour troisième trop tôt pour m'échauffer
et deux autres pour sa part qu'on passe
avant moi ils commencent à s'échauffer
assez vite je sens cette odeur
caractéristique l'odeur mêler de leur
sueur avec le cancre qui se sont enduits
sur sur les muscles qui envahit l'espace
à ça prend à la gorge
l'atmosphère devient étouffante derrière
dans les autres vestaires les boxeurs
centre nc s'échauffent en entrant on
entend ces ces bruits de frappe
puissante
qui résonne jusqu'à nous d'accord je
sers un peu voilà moi j'attends toujours
si les boxeurs vont être appelés à
monter sur le lit
l'un après l'autre je vais entendre leur
nom
émoussés par le speaker la poire
palmarès et puis toujours de mon
vestiaire je vais entendre les cris du
public les acclamations des silences
pendant les séquences du combat et vont
revenir le premier va revenir il a perdu
et des pc il est au bord des larmes sont
que je suis la tête basse
un peu plus tard c'est au tour du du
deuxième à l'huile à gagner est super
heureux toute sa troupe autour de lui
qui le fait rentrer dans le vestiaire il
brandit sa coupe chez un peu jalouse sa
victoire j'ai un peu jalouse de l'âge
délivrance
et puis ça va bientôt être un an à
l'organisateur arrive et me donne mais
quand de combat puis m'explique t le
combat vedette quand tu vas avoir le
cercle lumineux le projecteur est bien
dans le cercle lumineux ne sort pas
embauche de la musique tu n'avances pas
tant que ça n'a pas démarré vente cash
déteste tout ce truc là je déteste ça
donc répliqué rocky le tabloïd
très complet bon que je ne ferai pas mon
protège dont il me passe là bas j'ai lu
sur le visage ma serviette est prête
nous sommes aux abords de la sarre et la
main sur mon épaule je sens la chaleur
du projecteur sur mon visage
les pom pom girls qui agitent
frénétiquement leurs boules colorées et
à musique tonitruante qui démarré ce
héros qui évidemment j'avance au loin le
ring qui est flamboyant ses projecteurs
idée spectaculaire
je passe les cordes mais dans mon coin
est face à moi ma russe se tient droite
pierre est pas besoin de forcer le trait
pour l'alarmé chant premier coup de gong
de commandes de combat démarre très peu
d'observation on est en gardant
s'observe une deux secondes et tout de
suite ça démarre sur les chapeaux de
roue les coups fusent et frappe fort je
sens que que le combat va être dur
le ton est donné 2ème 3ème 4ème rang ça
s'enflamme le rythme s'emballe et
confuse
je bloque je pars j'esquive jeu rend
coup pour coup
la rue ces machines elle connaît bronche
pas son visage est toujours impassible
et jamais les d'expression de douleurs
de fatigue rien du tout elle même pas le
cligne des yeux fin du 4ème art en une
touche avec un coût de super puissant
dans la cuisse je sens qu'un muscle
c'est fabu y minutes de repos ça me
sauve en à l'appel du snj cameron le
combat reprend j'ai le musc et raser les
bras lourds les poumons en feu j'ai les
mots de mon coach qui résonne encore
dans ma tête
super gagné mais le turbo et âgées ou à
pied sur la d'accélérateur ça
marche pas la russe ancienne et l'ipod
touch avec un coup de pied circulaire os
x
j'ai la douleur qui nous traversent
comme une lame dans une sorte de réflexe
gérant un coup de pied frontale droite
uppercut gauche et pour la première fois
une histoire peu de signes est ici bien
sûr sont sur son visage et un regard
dans son coin comme un appel au secours
et là je sens il faut que je fasse
quelque chose et je décide de déclencher
un petit tournant qui demande beaucoup
d'énergie mais je me lance je vous
propose de le regarder en vidéo
je suis embêté
[Applaudissements]
et là j'ai battu la russe j'ai battu la
russie championne du monde
alors qu'est-ce qui a fait que j'ai
gagné ce combat s'est fait qu'on
intéresse
j'ai beaucoup creuser cette question
qu'est ce qu'a fait j'ai guéri ce combat
et puis finalement tous les autres alors
que vous allez dire c'est la préparation
physique à ce niveau là on a toutes les
deux une très bonne préparation physique
pour moi la réponse à se situer ailleurs
et j'ai envie de partager avec votre
moitié stratégique pour ça on va revenir
sur des petits moments clés de ce combat
donc est ce qui m'a permis de libérer le
potentiel de la petite fille fragile et
vulnérable
souvenez-vous l'attenté interminable
dans le vestiaire le stress la tension
si tout ça si je le laisse me contaminer
qu'est ce qui va se passer c'est le
doute les pensées négatives
la peur qui va s'installer si la peur
s'installe c'est la défaite avant même
d'avoir mis un terme
donc qu'est ce qui fait que je suis
encore motivé après trois ans d'attenté
qu'est ce qui fait que j'ai encore envie
de monter sur sa ligne pour me battre
pour moi c'est le sens qui nourrit ma
motivation
le sens c'est une question très simple
pourquoi
l'important c'est de faire pourquoi en
deux groupes
pourquoi la question est simple la
réponse il faut la creuse et faut aller
la chercher loin jusqu'à toucher quelque
chose qui résonne fort en soi moi
j'étais habité par la conviction que je
devais combattre mes peurs pour
m'autoriser à exister
c'était ça mon sens et chaque pas que je
le faisais vers le ring à me rapprocher
me rapprocher de ceux censés me
remplissait d'énergie les bantous
je vous invite vous aussi à questionner
votre sens surtout pour les actions
difficiles parce que le sens quand on le
touche
c'est un puissant moteur et c'est ce qui
permet vraiment de dépasser ce coup de
pied vous en souvenez douai ce qui
venait ce coup de pied c'est bien ça qui
m'a permis de gagner ce combat qui était
inhabituel
surprenant en boxe française scouts et
était inconnu
on ne pratiquait pas alors qu'est ce qui
m'a inspiré ce côté je n'ai pas inventé
là le jour j sur le combat c'est
l'exploration la deuxième clé
stratégique
donc je voulais vous parler mon coach
marc rivet a plein de compétition dans
d'autres disciplines
j'étais multi licenciés en techniques de
karaté comme vous je faisais toutes les
disciplines du coin toutes les
compétitions
son objectif c'est que je m'adapte à
toute situation à tous les styles
c'était aussi un formidable lieu
d'exploration
j'ai vu des techniques différentes des
déplacements différents et des coûts et
ce coup là cette pirouette à ses hôtes
et pando clé vous pour la première fois
alors on l'a travaillé beaucoup pour
l'adapter au contexte spécifique de la
boxe et c'est comme ça que j'ai pu la
mettre
mais ce coup dans ma brave dame aussi
l'exploration cm et chose pour par tous
en nous cette capacité à explorer
c'est si rappelez vous quand vous étiez
enfant vous poussiez une perte interdite
rappelez vous de ceux de cette émotion
de cette excitation très brive pour vous
pouviez avoir en poussant cette porte
avec la certitude que derrière il y
avait un trésor entre génial c'est de ça
dont il s'agit aussi de réveiller cette
envie-là d'explorer donc réveillé sa
poussée des pas sorties de zone de
confort avec l'intention délibérée de
faire des liens de faire des ponts et
c'est ça qui nourrit le terreau de
l'audace de votre dassin l'audace c'est
ma troisième clé stratégie parce que ce
coup de pied je l'avais dans ma boîte à
outils google
encore fallait-il décidé de le faire au
bon moment souvent en situation de crise
qu'est-ce qui se passe la tentation
c'est de faire plus de la même chose et
plus de la même chose une assistance qui
est souvent improductives saran
prévisible et une réponse qui fonctionne
dans un contexte venez nous ne sommes
pas forcément dans un bout de compte est
d'autant plus un contexte de crise il
faut alors décidé de faire autrement au
5e rang quand je suis justement dans la
dent may crise crise de ressources du
mal par tout le bien qu est ce qui fait
que je décide de faire autrement c'est
l'ouverture aux signaux extérieurs
même les plus faibles le regard de mon
adversaire dans son coin comme un appel
au secours à son coach c'est ce petit
signal qui m'autorise à faire se donne
utile vas-y beaux arts la voisine dans
vos situations de crise
ne laissez pas vos crises vous aveugle
et ouvrait rester à l'affût en veille de
tous les signes extérieurs même les plus
infimes parce que ce sont des cadeaux
les opportunités pour libérer votre das
le sens l'exploration l'audace ce sont
des clés que j'ai vraiment utilisé dans
tous les combats
tout ce que j'ai gagné là et ça marche
pour tous les combats il ya quatre ans
je me suis retrouvé paralysé des deux
jambes les médecins m'ont des boutiques
les maladies et m'ont dit que je
remarche serait plus jamais comme avant
voire même que ça pourrait sa table à
partir de là
vgg piste une et le sens ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pu parler j'ai
questionné le sens de cette maladie et
j'ai questionné le sens de ma vie en
fait je me suis aperçu que ce que je
choisis jusque là s'était éloigné de qui
j'étais je suis rendu compte que les
actions elle est en train de mener
n'était plus en phase avec ce que je
faisais c'est comme si la maladie me
disait stop tu continues plus comme ça
n'avance plus comme ça tu n'avances plus
comme ça et or j'ai exploré j'ai ouvert
des portes
j'ai retrouvé cette appétence joyeuse un
peu l'exploration j'ai rencontré des
gens formidables
j'ai appris plein de choses sur cette
maladie mais aussi sur moi et c'est ça
qui m'a permis de petit à petit d'ouvrir
la voie de la reconstruction et la
reconstruction pas ça non physique parce
qu'aujourd'hui je suis bien plus heureux
maintenant que je n'étais avant ma
maladie et donc je réalise que ces trois
clés c'est bien plus que des clés
d'efficacité c'est devenu pour moi une
sorte de philosophie de vie est strict
et vraiment pour moi des pieds de
bonheur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]